le portrait d'un pays entier sur un seul
point de rues de philadelphie des
américains divisé même sur la notion
fondamentale du dépouillement du vote
les partisans des deux camps
s'invectivent devant le centre des
congrès où l'on dénombre le vote postal
des résultats dans l'état de la
pennsylvanie sont très serrés chaque
vote peut faire pencher la balance d'un
côté on affirme qu'il faut compter
chaque bulletin rempli afin de protéger
la démocratie de l'autre on insiste sur
la nécessité de stopper le dépouillement
pour enrayer de possibles fraudes
électorales
petite victoire judiciaire en cour
d'appel de la pennsylvanie annoncé
triomphalement par le clan trump une
délégation de 15 observateurs
républicains pourra observer le comptage
à deux mètres de distance
une victoire pour tous ceux qui ont voté
légalement lance-t-il la commission
électorale de philadelphie porte la
décision en appel affirmant qu'il s'agit
d'une violation de la vie privée des
électeurs et des règles sanitaires en
pleine pandémie
pendant ce temps à pittsburgh où près de
30000 vote font l'objet d'une
contestation judiciaire
le dépouillement est suspendu
plus de job de marque des points plus
l'équipe de doan tran multiplie les
recours judiciaires pour faire cesser le
comptage des votes dans plusieurs états
après les démarches annoncé au oui ce
concert et en pennsylvanie après avoir
été débouté en cour au michigan le
nevada est dans la mire des républicains
à la présidence américaine est en jeu et
il faut arrêter de compter des bulletins
de vote et légaux dit il ceux qui
souhaitent la défaite de nos troupes ne
sont pas surpris l'amérique diviser son
temps sur une chose la bataille
judiciaire sur les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle ne fait que
commencer ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada philadelphie